qu'est ce que l'école c'est l'éducation
pour tous moi je trouve ça génial
c'est même une chance et pourtant tout
le monde ici talent à l'école vous en
souvenez les enfants sont globalement
pas très content d'y aller mais il se
trouve que les enseignants partagent le
même sentiment
mais vous trouvez pas ça bizarre vous de
se retrouver un endroit pour pas être
content est ce que c'est le meilleur
moyen d'apprendre et d'enseigner de ne
pas être content j'ai le temps de me
poser un peu la question et j'aimerais
partager avec vous un retour
d'expérience et pas une vérité
universelle c'est juste un témoignage
mais un ressenti les miens en maternelle
je commence à vouloir apprendre à lire
mais mes parents veulent que je fasse
comme tout le monde et apprennent à lire
seulement à partir du cp alors
j'apprends à lire tout seul en lisant
les panneaux publicitaires dans la rue
en primaire je me retrouve donc en cp où
j'apprends les sons qui me manquait en
lecture dans une classe là je me demande
tiens mais pourquoi on appelle une
classe une classe là pour classer pour
classer quoi bas pour classer les gens
effectivement cp on nous note et on nous
classe et on nous classe en fonction des
notes et j'apprends par la même occasion
les mots récréation au passage vous
laisse vous demandez ce que veut dire le
mot récréation qu'est ce qu'on y fait
précisément dans une récréation le mot
surveillants surveillants qui peuvent
vous engueuler parce que vous marchez
dans une flaque d'eau et aussi les mots
classement de voir punition et un jour j
à ma mère que si on force à y retourner
je me jette sous une voiture mes paroles
prennent sérieusement alors je change
d'école et j'enchaîne ensuite les
classes de cp ce1 ce2 jusqu'à arriver en
cm1 ou là je découvre un truc que
j'avais encore jamais vu dans une classe
avant de l'entr'aide et du partage
dans cette classe particulière à double
niveau le but c'est que les cm1 aide les
ce2 que ceux qui ont des facilités est
ce avec des difficultés et c'est ça qui
est génial
que
bon il ya toujours des notes et du
classement mais l'entrée de change tout
et là les élèves sont vraiment heureux
mais bon le miracle dure pas si
longtemps que ça puisque la end après je
me retrouve dans une classe de cm2 avec
un prof qui a une représentation
médiocre des élèves sur tous avec des
difficultés il prend un malin plaisir à
se moquer d'eux a lancé leurs cahiers
par la fenêtre à jeter leurs affaires
par la porte et il met les autres élèves
dans une position à deux voix rigoler de
aussi bon moi je fais pas spécialement
partition avec des difficultés mais je
met constamment à leur place et je
n'arrive pas à supporter tout ce qu'ils
endurent
bon je veux bien croire que c'est un cas
particulier
tous les profs sont pas comme ça et
heureusement mais ça change rien au
résultat parce que le stress dû à cette
éducation violente est tellement gros
que je suis une tentative de suicide
après cette année vous retrouve au
collège je fais ma sixième rob bagg avec
la cinquième sur ma quatrième pour faire
ma troisième chez moi avec le cned tout
ça pour enfin arriver au lycée à l'école
boulle l'école boulle
c'est une école qui forme aux métiers
d'art et moi choisi d'aller dans
l'atelier de gravure en mode la danse
atelier je veux faire de la gravure du
modelage du moulage du dessin de la
peinture qui vous permettra ensuite de
créer par exemple des pièces de monnaie
des médailles des jouets des figurines
des pendentifs et dans cet atelier
miracle je retrouve ce que j'avais vécu
en cm1 de l'entr'aide entre les élèves
et le professeur du partage et surtout
de l'envi dans cet atelier on n'a pas de
devoirs pas de contrôler les travaux sur
lesquels on travaille c'est nous qui les
choisissent on est les seules notes
qu'on a on les choisit ensemble avec le
professeur ce qui fait que les notes
sont plus subi ou infliger mais
entièrement voulue et assumée par les
élèves
mais à côté de l'atelier il ya encore
les autres matières qui fonctionne avec
le même fonctionnement de notes et de
et de et de classements qu'avant avec 41
heures de cours par semaine plus les
deux voire même pendant les vacances
si les vacances ça sert à faire des
devoirs autant pas avoir de vacances
donc re bugs et je me retrouve dans ce
qu'on pourrait appeler un échec scolaire
et là je pose une question qu'est ce
qu'un échec scolaire
est ce que c'est un échec de l'élève ou
est ce que c'est un échec de l'école
est-ce que c'est au pied de convenir à
la chaussure ou est ce que c'est la
chaussure de convenir aux pieds sans
doute un peu des deux si on va plus loin
les valeurs de l'école l'éducation pour
tous moi je trouve ça génial c'est mais
c'est une chance et même un cadeau à
prendre mais j'adore ça j'ai même
regardé l'intégralité des c'est pas
sorcier pendant on est cinquièmes les
matières des cols bleus sont super
intéressante français maths svt quoi que
l'histoire se concentre un peu trop sur
le côté négatif du passé vous savez avec
les gens qui se tapent dessus pour se
prendre ce qu'ils ont pour s'imposer
leur mode de vie
mais bon alors qu'est-ce qui bug moi bah
je me posais la question que vous posez
probablement tous suis-je normal alors
je cherche et un truc qui me turlupine
ckoi l'organe qu'on nous demande
d'utiliser à l'école une basse le
cerveau mais comment fonctionne un
cerveau on vous l'a déjà expliqué vous à
l'école
moi je n'ai alors j'ai utilisé
l'entr'aide le partage et l'intelligence
collective mais j'ai posé la question
autour de moi il ya deux réponses qui
m'ont parlé la première c'est que le
cerveau apprend en faisant des erreurs
faire des erreurs c'est le moyen le plus
naturel du cerveau pour apprendre et la
deuxième c'est que la peur réduit les
capacités d'apprentissage
vous voyez où je veux en venir est-ce
que ça serait pas les moyens qu'utilise
l'école pour nous faire partager ses
belles valeurs contre heureux
questionner lorsqu'on donne une note à
un élève avec un chiffre comme 5 par
exemple l'élève at il ce chiffre où est
il ce chiffre est pourquoi on appelle un
élève en élèves
pour l'élever mais lorsqu'on rend des
devoirs de la meilleure et la moins
bonne note
est ce qu'on élève l'élève quelle que
soit la note ça serait pas plus
intéressant de se réjouir de ce qu'on a
obtenu plutôt que de se lamenter de ce
qu'on n'a pas atteint
parce que n'importe quelle note surtout
basse lorsqu'elle est infligée est une
humiliation
alors que lorsqu'elle est choisie et une
acceptation la question intéressante
apposa élèves serait pas plutôt quelle
valeur a tous envie de te donner
classement note de voir évaluation
humiliation punition compétition
dépression etc tous ces mots mention il
n'aurait pas polluer les belles valeurs
de l'école et si l'école ne redevenait
écologique parce que c'est sous tous ces
mentions citer qu'eux se trouve en celui
l'entr'aide le partage et l'éducation
pour tous le scud mois en privilégiant
les valeurs de compétition à celle
d'entraidé de partage
est-ce que l'école prépare à un vent
dures et injustes ou escales serait pas
en train de le créer si les valeurs
d'entraidé le partage était devant celle
de compétition escudé constructeurs
automobiles tricheraient sur les
voitures qui sont construites on dit que
l'union fait la force alors pourquoi
l'école se consentent pas plus sur
l'union que sur la rivalité
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait
déjà on demande leur avis aux enfants
sur l'école vous accepteriez vous de
vivre ce qu'on appelle le bel âge dans
un endroit où on vous demande jamais
votre avis
ça ça sera un lien de confiance est le
meilleur moyen pour quelqu'un vous
fassent confiance se serait pas lui
faire aussi confiance on pourrait aussi
commencer par rebaptisé l'école
aujourd'hui un lp c'est un lycée
d'enseignement professionnel
ça vous donne envie d'y aller imaginez
que demain comme ça par magie un lep ça
devienne un lieu d'entraidé et de
partage
elle est comment votre envie en
préparant cette intervention
je suis tombé sur une citation de
frederick douglass qui était un homme
politique américain qui est né esclave
qui dit il est plus facile de construire
des enfants solide que de réparer des
adultes brisé parce que ce qui est
important c'est ça c'est l'envié ce
qu'il faut garder allumée
parce que tout simplement envie ça veut
dire en vie merci